ladies and gentlemen every once in a
while i see something so stupid that i
just have to call it out goldman sachs
recently put out a report they included
a chart that shows bitcoin and ethereum
users what they're trying to show in
this chart is that the ethereum users
supposedly are way more interested way
more popular than the bitcoin usage well
if we zoom in on the chart and start to
pay attention this is just bad math
ladies and gentlemen the blue line is
bitcoin addresses with greater or equal
to 0.01 bitcoin
and then the ethereum that's that black
line is balances with 0.01 or more
ethereum in the wallet address sounds
fine right
well the difference is that that's 400
worth of bitcoin versus about 30 of
ethereum so naturally they're comparing
apples to oranges this chart means
nothing it's literally just the
manipulation of data it's trying to
twist a narrative that not only is wrong
but also it leads people to bad
conclusions as i always say you have to
have good data to have good analysis
this is bad data these two things aren't
correlated at all and ultimately goldman
sachs it's not their expertise i don't
think that they're being nefarious i
just think that they made a mistake but
you got to be careful you have to always
do your own research you have to think
for yourself and make sure that when you
see a chart that looks this absurd
read the fine print bitcoin at 400
versus ethereum at 30
what are those two things have to do
with each other
nothing and so stay safe out there my
friends
data can say anything hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time